hello everyone and welcome back to the
quarterfinals of the chest bull masters
finals it's Hikaru Nakamura versus ding
Levin and this is the second game of the
first match the first game ended in a
draw and here are Hikaru now has the
white pieces it's quite the game so
let's dive straight into Hikaru with the
white pieces opens with E for weave if I
from ding Knight to f3 and 9th to c6
forgot that and Bishop to b5 Hikaru goes
for the rule opus and the dingoes for
the Berlin defence so Knight of 6 we
have d3 and Bishop to c5 so it's gonna
be the standard main line of the Berlin
the ship captures we have D captures and
now just castles and now black will do
something about this 'if I've won that's
under attack so Knight goes to d7 in the
future you might choose to play some
like f6 and so on yeah so Knight B to d2
preparing Knight to c4 to put additional
pressure to the pawn and black castles
we have Knight to c4 now black needs the
the goddess and rook to e8 now which is
the main move here f6 isn't on move
however it was only played in in a
handful of games with a 4 now preparing
to expand further on the Queen side with
a 4 a 5 maybe C 3 B 4 and so on and the
black prevents this by pushing a 5 and
here there are a few games where b3 was
played they're skiing to h1 also no move
but h4 the multicolored place is a new
move in the position so already as a
move 10 we have a completely new game so
let's see LX see what happens with
Knight to b6 being offers a trade of
nights here as it is it is a very strong
night but also he kind of leaves the e5
pawn undefended so it's very interesting
what or what's happening here point is
if both of the Knights capture the pawn
or at least if only one of the in
captures let's say you go Knight F
characters here then you will pick up
this knight first and then of course
after this knife characters you lose the
h4 pawn so that's the idea so it's not
really a pawn sacrifice here we have
Knight back the e3 doesn't allow this
and now comes Bishop captures on e3 and
he core doesn't recapture with the
bishop which seems reasonable but the
problem
if you recapture with the bishop Dan
Bishop to g4 is very strong and as you
already pushed upon 2 H 4 you don't have
h3 to click away the bishop and this
will be a very annoying pain pin pretty
much for the rest of the game so here
instead hikaru captures with the F pawn
nicely opens up be a file and will be
used for attacking and defensive
purposes and our Bishop to g4 isn't
really a problem you can just on pin
because the rook also defends the night
so tonight's the d7 thing now wants to
shift to the night over to have sex and
the bush of the d2 hikaru is preparing
Bishop to c3 to go after the e5 pawn
this way Knight to have six and now that
night the h2 stopping any any any of the
pieces from coming to g4 but also may be
preparing to infiltrate via D squares so
h5 not allowing any g4 plants from white
but also you can also use it as an
outpost for your knight or the bishop so
Queen to f3 and now Queen to e7 putting
more defense to the f7 pawn so the
knight can now move as the Queen and the
rook battery were very very annoying
here so brush up the c3 hikaru yuri
maneuvers the bishop to a more useful
diagonal and now c5 i think also still
has to decide how to develop his light
square bishop well he goes something
like Bishop to e6 maybe Bishop to g4 in
the future or maybe b7 Bishop to b7 and
to put the bishop on this diagonal so b3
by Hikaru
and now Knight to g4 saying ok you can
capture here and then I can develop my
Bishop to g4
this should be back to e 1 is also ding
is now just attacking the h4 point so he
Carl Joe's defense at Bishop to e1 and
now rook the a6 and here Dean says that
he's ready to attack he Carlos king he
wants to shift the rock over to g6 and
it will be a very strong look so rush up
to g3 and now comes Rock to g6 as
planned
we have Knight captures on g4 otherwise
this night will come to h6 this will
open up the G fall for the rook and it
could be a bit dangerous so he card
decides to eliminate one of the
attackers Knight captures on g4 we have
Bishop captures with an attack on the
Queen and Queen f2 so rook to b8 in the
future you might be able to open up the
D file and all
so maybe you can maybe you can also
include this rook into the attacks on
how so king h2 are getting to the king
to a safer Square in the b6 now we have
Queen to d2
now with ideas of maybe infiltrating
with the Queen this way maybe somehow
and f6 now just defending the e5 pawn
and now the black Queen can move as well
we have print the c3 and now rook the d6
so bringing the other work to the 6th
rank as well we have rook to f2 with
ideas of maybe doubling up on the F file
and king h7 binding we have rook a to f1
and now rush of the back to e6 so here
you can see that the position is very
closed and it's not all that easy to
make any sort of a breakthrough it's not
like completely closed breakthroughs are
possible at some point white might have
d4 planned black might have c6 be five
plants so there are breakthroughs in the
position so rook F 3 and now rook the g4
by Hikaru
now black might have some ideas of maybe
f5 rook characters here maybe
sacrificing the exchange to create some
sort of an attack so Queen back to e1
adding more protection to the bishop but
also to the h4 pawn and now Queen back
to e8 we have King back to h1 and now
Queen to g6 now again putting pressure
on the bishop here Queen f2 it's not
really not really a problem the bishop
is well defended and the Queen back to
eh now so rook to a-1 Hikaru just asking
being what are you planning here as ding
is the one who is pretty much dictating
the tone of the battle Hikaru can just
wait and see what happens and here ding
played King to g8 it was at some point
that Hikaru
I think offered the draw I don't know in
which position exactly and ding declined
I didn't wanted to play the position on
and here ding played King to g8 and it
was in this moment that Magnus Carlsen
tweeted a tweet
regarding this position where he said
that the black king landing on b7 for
sure hashtag study chest so Magnus
claims that the king that now came to g8
is coming all the way to b7 so this is
what Magnus says that the King has to be
brought all the way here if you want to
push this game for something more so we
have Bishop to h2 he car wants to play
rogue g3 trade off a pair of rooks
and we have looked back to g6 queen back
to f1 and now Queen to d7 we have worked
to be won by Hikaru and rook the g4 now
again putting pressure on the h4 pawn so
rook the g3 now asking do you want to
trade rooks here and now it seems like
you could capture the pawn on h4 however
if you capture the pawn on h4 then Queen
captures on f6 is happening as now you
cannot capture due to the pin and also
well the rook is under attack so you
don't want to allow white any tricks
like this so then captures with rook
captures and g3 we have Bishop captures
and g3 and now Bishop to g4 so dings
still waiting for with his King March we
look back to a1 and now Queen to e6 we
have Queen to f2 Hikari just has to wait
and see and now being starts the King
March King to f7 so let's see if he does
what Magnus tweeted about we have looked
back to f1 and now King t8 we have Queen
back the e1 and now King to d7 we have
Queen to c3 and now King to see it we
have King to g1 and now King Tubby 7
it's as if ding saw crossings tweet and
the King does land on b7 so looked after
by Hikaru and now Queen back to EA 8
we looked earth one Hikaru just has to
wait and see what happens and Queen to
g6 now we have King to h2 and now Russia
back the e6 preparing to bring the Queen
over to g4 we have Queen that II won and
now Queen to g4 so what what is things
planned here we have Queen back the sea
3 by Hikaru and Russia back to d7 now we
have Queen back to e1 he call just
repeats and Bishop the c6 now now you
have to be careful if you place the
Queen somewhere like d1 or d2 than rush
of characters here is an option since
the phone will not be able to recapture
so Queen to have to and now look back to
d8
we have worked to a 1 and now rook the
h8 so pretty much just using every
possible resource to give Hikaru well a
potential opportunity to blunder
something so here he car offers the
Queen trade ding declines Queen back to
e6 and
roll back 2 F 1 we have Quinta e 2 I saw
it first rook to h6 and now Quinta e 2
and now Queen back to ei so still
nothing really going on we have Queen
back to d1 and now we have worked the h8
biding we have Bishop the e1 and now
Bishop to d7 with King to h1 and now
Queen to g6 so something has to happen
or if you know they just keep repeating
moves then it's gonna be a draw by 50
move rule I don't know if they have such
a rule in online chess but I mean I'm
pretty sure they do why wouldn't they
so King to h2 and now rook the d8 for
those of you who don't know the 50 move
rule if nothing happens over the course
of 50 moves then it's a draw and by
nothing happens I mean if no pieces are
captured and no pawns are captured or no
pawns are pushed so Bishop the g3 just
repeating and here Queen to g4 now it's
Dean who offers a queen trade and Hikaru
happily exchanges so Queen captures with
Bishop characters and now King to g1
so how will dink do anything to try and
push for more than a draw here dingos c6
so he he says that he might be
interested in going b5 rook to a1 by
Hikaru if b5 is played captures captures
you want to have the a five point
undefended so ding just defends it with
rook to e8 and now the Shabak to e 1 we
have b5 by dink
and now King to f1 Hikaru also starts
bringing his King into the game King
Tubby 6 and now Bishop to c3
we're before pushing the bishop back and
now Bishop to b2 and now with the
position again closed on the Queen side
again it's very hard to defer to see
what what being is interested in doing
here so look back to d8 biding and now
Kim tae-won we have king to c7 now Dean
shifts the King back into the center
King to D to end now King to d6 we wrote
back to f1 and now King to e6
we have King Teti won again and just
repeating and rook the g8 now here ding
is preparing g5 as this is well aside
from f5 the only breakthrough he has in
the position so King F 2 and now he goes
for the g5 he
traits characters captures and now King
to g3
ding wants to play h4 here so he carve
stops at with the king now if h4 you
just gobble up the bishop so look back
to d8 by dink and here rook to f2 and
now a very interesting attempt by dink
he pushes c4 here and c4 is very
interesting because if you capture with
this point then do these two points are
extremely weak and you also free up the
D file to be used for your rook so he
car instead goes B captures on c4 but
now c5 and again think what the dink
managed to do here is that he
successfully created a week a for pawn
and you might be able to use the bishop
to attack at somehow maybe you can move
the king bringing the bishop here attack
it this way or maybe you can attack at
front from behind
we'll see so here he Carl goes rook to
beat you now he says he might be
interested in maybe some c3 d4 action
but now just rook the c8 biding and here
alright the position is well very calm
nothing is actually happening here
and he Carlos should just repeat moves
as he did basically for the entire game
something like rook 2f to maybe look
back the d2 king h2 or something but
here he can play Bishop to a-1 and it
seems like it's the same thing you just
want to bring the bishop back and forth
however this move loses the game for
white it's really it's weird but it does
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning move for dink
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on realizing that the
bishop on a1 is undefended and this is
what makes blacks next move possible and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
show its rook to f8 a rook to f8 without
with the blush of being on beat you
would not be as potent because now when
the rook comes to f1 you already have an
attack on the bishop so that's the
problem here and the problem is you
don't have root F to do to prevent dings
rook from infiltrating because of h4
check and now the King has to move and
you win the rope here on f2 well the
exchange basically so after Luke to f8
he Carl tried c3 but now adding just
goes in with the rook rook to f1 the
bishop here on a1
now under attack you have to defend it
Bishop to b2 and now comes the shock to
D 1 as the rook from f1 nicely defends
the bishop which attacks da for pawn
which will create some past points on
the Queen side so here he color played
before but now here didn't just played
h4 with Czech you cannot go to h3 fking
each three than rook to h1 is checkmate
as both of these squares are nicely
covered so you the king has nowhere to
go so instead he calculated king to h2
but here didn't just played g4 and it
was in this position unmoved ad that hit
Cara Nakamura resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here whatever
you do it's just game over let's say we
try the five checking these six and now
any move like really like you could try
giving up the exchange but that end game
is still lost so let's say any other
move just results in g3 check King h3
only move and the rook the h1 is
checkmate so really really awesome stuff
being really squeezed the the water out
of stone in this one and well Hikaru
defended perfectly well but at at some
point where he needed to just to defend
moves here with anything except Bishop
to a-1 he played Bishop day one it's
just just amazing but that's the point
being tried for for like 60 moves to try
and get hit hard to make one small
inaccuracy he did it and dink took
advantage of that and won the game so
really a brilliant game so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Mark Epstein Jordan Koch
Marco who taking Rajpur and Thomas
Mumford for a contribution to my channel
think you want to really appreciate it
it's also it's also Thomas's birthday so
I wish you all the best
you know in life and also over the
chessboard so I think you're I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day